there are 50 different types of fears
that hold most people back but there's a
common seven or so so fear of failure
fear of succeeding and failing fear of
trying my best and disappointing myself
for others fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged all of these
fears have to do with our self-image
self-esteem and self-worth and what will
I think of me or what will others think
of me if I don't succeed or if I do and
fail so fears are naturally occurring
phenomenon in our subconscious mind as a
safety and protective mechanism to keep
us away from any danger or real or
imagined pain or suffering and so it's
just an automatic trigger in the
subconscious mind now the problem is not
fear the problem is that most people
don't understand that fear it's just a
signal it's a highly sensitive signal in
mechanism in the brain but the
ramifications of not understanding what
fear does is the problem
John Assaraf in the building how are you
man in the building Here I am doing
great we're part we're separated by sea
but we're all connected right that's
that's absolutely true I'm super super
excited to speak to you today so thank
you
people who might seen you on the secret
or no use best-selling author or you
know endlessly successful entrepreneur
with multiple projects and stuff like
that do you think that you were
naturally gifted to be successful in
this many domains is this kind of what
you thought you were going to end up
doing when you were younger
no I I was voted most likely to fail in
life by my grade 11 students and my my
basketball team that I I excelled in
basketball when I was a kid every
thought I was going to be a you know a
jock you know an athlete of some sort
they they used to say you know he's
brilliant on the basketball court but
he's dumber than a doorknob in the
classroom and so I I never thought I
would be doing what I do today I never
believed that I could I thought it was
way too dumb I was I was hungry but I
was I just felt like I wasn't as smart
as the other kids I mean my I I grew up
in a family with you know hard-working
parents who wanted to put food on the
table for their kids we lived in
moderate moderate moderate you know
means you know it's I had a bedroom with
my brother my sister had a bedroom we
had an apartment there was always
arguments and fights around the lack of
money my father was a gambler and an
alcoholic I believe he hasn't drank in
probably 50 years but so a lot of
struggles and and then I I didn't have
the environment that really fostered me
even thinking about achieving success
until I had one chance encounter with
one man when I was 19 years old who
asked me one question and the answer to
that question changed my life but up
until the age of 19 I thought I was you
know gonna work
in a factory making minimum wage living
in a average place was struggling for
money struggling to make a great life
for myself the only great life that I
ever had in my imagination was from
watching television I suppose when you
don't have that role model there's a lot
of people now who might not have that
close to them you know especially I
think the generational gap that has
occurred within the last 50 years is
really different you know when you think
about the sort of opportunities that
became available to you and are now
available to the people that are
listening a young age unbelievable
worlds apart right and the sometimes we
might get a little bit resentful of our
parents I know that you've mentioned in
previous interviews that you had a
little bit of resentment towards not
being given the tools necessarily to do
what you wanted to do but from a much
more compassionate side it's a total
different operating system now right but
the rules that that control the old
world don't really it's a lot harder for
our parents to think about how to apply
those to what's going on now yeah you
know I remember I used to live in this
neighborhood and in between the
neighborhood that I lived in and the
other affluent neighborhood there was a
community center and so some of the kids
in my neighborhood you know couldn't
afford to be members of the community
center even though it wasn't very
expensive and then there were other kids
on the other side of the street that
their parents had a little bit more
money nicer cars nicer homes and I used
to meet these kids at the community
center and he used to go over to their
house and I remember you know used to
feel like I wish my you know
specifically my father because back in
those days moms were mostly stay-at-home
took care of the kids and maybe they'd
work which my mother did but I used to
remember feeling I wish my father was as
smart as his father or her father and I
wish that we were able to go on
vacations and to you know buy nice
clothes instead of you know the ratty
jeans and the ratty coats you know that
I always felt were less than the other
kids
and what I realized as I got older was
you know my parents just did the best
they could my father went to grey
like three or four you know my mother
also grade three or four then they went
to work at fifteen sixteen years old to
try and make ends meet during the war
you know said they didn't have an
education they didn't have a chance to
do anything other than survive and they
didn't know that they could do more they
just believed they were born in this
environment that they were victims of
that environment that you know they had
to make ends meet and struggle and and
there was scarcity and that the rich
people you know they you know they
either did it illegally or they had
these belief systems you know that we're
just disempowering them and they didn't
know that they were disempowered you
know back then you know if you want to
learn you'd either go to school read
books listen to the radio you know and
today the least of our concerns is
knowing how do I do X how do I achieve Y
if you want to be healthy if you want to
be happy if you want to make more money
if you want to build a business you want
to write a book you want to fill in the
blank I want to blank you can google it
and in in less than three minutes you
can have a step-by-step blueprint of
exactly what to do today's problem isn't
that the how-to doesn't exist
it's all of the internal [ __ ] that
people are dealing with that holds them
back their fears of failure or fears of
what will people think of me on social
media if I try and I fail or I
disappoint them you know what will
people feel if I'm not doing this or
doing that so there's a much bigger
internal game going on right now around
fears and self-image and limiting
beliefs that most people are totally
unaware is happening and that is really
causing them to be stuck in this limited
cycle and self-fulfilling prophecies
that cause them to achieve way less than
they're capable of achieving do you
think that that's the primary issue that
people are coming up against
self-limiting beliefs we've got the how
it's yeah that is that the main
roadblock people need to get over
there's only four there's there's only
four so from a
purely neuroscience neuropsychology
perspective what we know about the brain
is there are 50 different types of fears
that hold most people back but there's a
common seven or so so fear of failure
fear of succeeding and failing fear of
trying my best and disappointing myself
or others fear of being embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged all of these
fears have to do with our self-image
self-esteem and self-worth and what will
I think of me or what will others think
of me if I don't succeed or if I do and
fail that's the more so fears are
naturally occurring phenomenon in our
subconscious mind as a safety and
protective mechanism to keep us away
from any danger or real or imagined pain
or suffering and so it's just an
automatic trigger in the subconscious
mind and fear happens to be one of our
six core emotions now the problem is not
fear the problem is that most people
don't understand that fear is the
equivalent of driving your car and a
dash light popping up on your on your on
your dash it's just a signal
it's a highly sensitive signal in
mechanism in the brain but the
ramifications of not understanding what
fear does is the problem
so when fear activates in the brain it
releases cortisol or epinephrine or
norepinephrine it takes blood away from
the thinking part of the brain into the
motor cortex and the reactive part of
the brain and the untrained person will
react over and over and over and over
again to the highest level of training
that they've had around emotional
management so what causes you or me to
react as a result of fear may not cause
the same reaction let's say a Navy SEAL
or an astronaut you know who is used to
understanding that feeling and they know
how to control it so they can respond
instead of react so fear is number one
number two is limiting beliefs
I'm too young to do that I'm too old to
do that I'm too Asian or to Caucasian
you know I only went to grade blank in
school therefore I'm not smart enough
not good enough not worthless all of
these limiting beliefs actually
formulate the lens by which our brain
sees the world but more importantly than
that the limiting belief sets up what we
will do or don't do so it affects
behaviors so we had fears number one two
limiting beliefs then three let's say
somebody's watching they have a vision
or a goal doesn't make a difference we
know what kind of vision or goal it is
but let's say that at the conscious
level I want that I see me having that
being that doing that but if at the
subconscious level there is an opposing
belief an implicit belief or a
self-image that says but I'm not good
enough I'm not smart if I'm not worthy
of that yet or now then our subconscious
self-image will recalibrate what we do
or don't do so that's the third thing
and then the fourth thing which is a
little bit more real is when we don't
have the knowledge or the skill
currently to achieve the goal that we
want then we set off a circuit in the
brain which is the doubt surfeit the
uncertainty circuit its triggers the
self-image circuit and the fear circuit
as well so they're all interconnected so
if we don't have the knowledge or skill
and we feel doubtful then doubtful
actually activates you know these other
circuits are saying hold on if you're
doubtful if you're uncertain put the
brakes on don't put your foot on the gas
so what I do and what am I company does
we study the mechanisms by which all of
these things are turned on or off all
these triggers are turned on or off that
drives the behavior that causes the
results so I never focus on the results
themselves I always focus on what's
driving the behaviors that cause me to
take action or not take action and
that's really the work that I do and why
I wrote you know my book inner sighs
which I know you're familiar with and
some of my other stuff is let's get into
the
the neuro psychology of what's happening
in there how that's a framework yeah I
mean it's it's incredibly simple when
you look at it like that but it's so
messy right we're living in our heads we
have all of these signals going on we
have all of these very there notions you
know they're not they're not inputs and
outputs the way that we consciously
experience our own day to day life is
real ephemeral difficult to define stuff
right so how can we break through that
noise what is some of the strategies
that we can use to bring a little bit of
order to that chaos well I think first
we have to understand that you know we
are the most advanced you know
biological neurological you know
coalesce group of cells and atoms in the
known universe the only thing more
advanced than we are is the actual
universe itself and what it does so if
it's true that I have a brain I'm not my
brain but I have a brain then the next
question is is it possible for me to use
my brain better if my brain is
processing 400 billion bits of
information per second without me being
aware of it is it possible for me to be
able to direct my brain to look for
things that are more aligned with what
it is that I want to achieve do or
become yes it is possible is it possible
to understand that I was not born and
nobody listening or watching was born
with one belief one perspective one
habit one self-image not one person was
born with any of those which means that
somehow the constructs that I have
within my brain the patterns within my
brain were created either by my parents
my teachers my experiences what I read
what I wrote what I watched what I felt
is it possible that all our brain is is
a network of reinforced patterns
that we can learn how to be aware of a
limiting belief and let it go and create
a new empowering belief is it possible
that you know the habits that are
constructive and empower me we can
reinforce and the habits that are
nothing more than automatic patterns in
my brain that were created the ones that
are disempowering me is it possible that
I could learn the anatomy of a habit
which is a trigger a behavior and a
reward trigger behavior reward if I
could learn the anatomy of that then can
I let go of disempowering habits and
create empowering ones yes can I create
constructive habits that become my
Keystone habits that allow me to grow
right and evolve in a way that empowers
me in my life versus one that this
empowers me in my life and the answer is
yes so anybody who was watching what I
really want them to understand is you
are not a victim of your circumstance or
your conditions the only way you're a
victim of your circumstances or
conditions or past is if you take that
role on and as part of your identity
versus saying regardless of mice current
circumstances my knowledge my skills my
beliefs I can change and now I can learn
how to use the most powerful tool that I
already own called my brain I love it I
want to pick up on some of the
terminology views there I know that you
like to be very precise with your speech
and you like to lead with their
terminology which i think is something
I've worked on very hard over the last
few years and I absolutely love the way
that you do it too you've chosen to use
the term disempower and empower habits
rather than good and bad why it's not
binary it's not you know positive or
negative it's it's it's it's a frame you
know as soon as I say the word
negative everybody has a connotation
that that word means something bad and I
just look at it as it just is and the
question is can i frame things in a way
that lifts me up as a human being
instead of puts me down like something
is wrong and we you know we're used to
this positive and negative good bad what
about it just is is this thought process
going to help me achieve my goal or move
me away from it is this habit move me
towards what I want or away from what I
want is this person is this strategy is
this tactic is this you know emotion one
that empowers me or disempowers me okay
if it disempowers you if it's not to
your taste
you are at choice you see the greatest
gift we have as as a species is
awareness we can have a thought and we
can be aware and know that we have a
thought it's going a little bit deeper
than the norm right so we are not just
self-aware but we could be aware that
we're self-aware so if I understand that
I am NOT my thoughts I'm not my emotions
I'm not my feelings I'm not my
sensations not my behaviors are not my
results I have those then the question
is well if I have them can I choose ones
that are better for me for what I want
to achieve and become and do and have
and the answer is apps of [ __ ] lutely
that's your power and so soon as you
give away your power you're a victim and
so you know if you study any human
beings who have you know failed they
will all tell you that yes
I failed yes I was in a state of pain
panic suffering etc and it was one of
the best things in my life because I
used it and I framed it in a way that
empowered me and
of disempowered me so we have that
ability to take things and give them
meanings that lifts us up versus
terraced down and so what if we started
that with ourselves and then what if we
did that with each other it'll be a much
better world then what right and so but
it starts with self right because the
more I could be aware of you know what's
happening within me the more I can have
control the more I can respond instead
of react the more I could be deliberate
versus you know reacting automatically
and it all begins with awareness it all
begins with awareness of the gifts that
you already possess it's are you already
own the greatest gift in the known
universe but the lack of skill of how do
I use it is really the biggest challenge
people have and so the work that I do is
all around reom powering people to say
okay I have the ability to do what I
choose now how do I do that is the
reason that we toward fear and
negativity is it purely Fitness
enhancing is it purely an evolutionary
byproduct that's it yeah so the the
number one responsibility of our brain
Homo erectus has been walking around
this earth for about two and a half
billion years two and a half million
excuse me two and a half million years
so the evolution of our species is
survival above all else right so so
every living organisms number one
priorities biologically widen to us for
survival so the mechanisms of evolution
have created a brain that is nothing
more than electromagnetic switching
station right so light comes in through
our eyes sound comes in through our ears
signals come in through our senses
whether it's all factory sense of smell
or hands tactile and it is being
processed in the brain and the number
one algorithm is is there real danger
here that could cause me to die number
two is there any potential danger here
you know where I can get mentally
emotionally physically financially hurt
that's number two number three is energy
conservation so that number one and two
can happen so the processing mechanism
of our brain I know I know that you know
you're looking at me through the camera
and I'm looking at you and we see this
physical body with eyes and a nose and a
mouth in the ears strip that away and
what are you you're this brain with the
nervous system okay that is processing
all of this information for survival
right for avoidance of pain for energy
conservation and oh yeah by the way if
we can get some pleasure via sex or food
or playing with our telephones or
playing games we'll do that once one two
and three are met so we have been
evolving for two-and-a-half million
years to make sure that that happens now
throughout our lives and maybe even at a
cellular level we have memories of
things that have caused us or our
parents or our teachers or our brother
or sister pain suffering death or
whatever the case is and our brain is
processing this information so all of
the incoming thoughts or ideas you know
that we see in the outside world or even
our own thoughts of of achieving X Y or
Z it's all processed through these
algorithms to say okay in the memory
bank of your life and maybe even your
DNA is there anything in that loop okay
that could potentially be affecting your
survival or cause you pain or suffering
so as soon as there's a match inside our
brain through the neural networks a
signal is sent in a billionth of a
second called fear that's that's the
signal it's just it we call it fear but
just a signal of pay attention stop put
the brakes on what's going on right and
what most people don't understand is
fear is just the signal
and in many cases it doesn't mean stop
it just means be aware and then make a
choice in a decision but most people
have never been taught how to be aware
of this feeling and frame it in a way
that there's nothing wrong it's just a
really sensitive signal now let me use
my higher cortical functions called the
left prefrontal cortex and say this is
real danger or is it imagined danger is
it because of something that's happened
in the past or is it something that's
happening right in this moment that's
really really you know dangerous and in
that nanosecond of awareness and choice
we could learn how to make better
decisions where fear can be turned into
fuel because the that little anxiety are
stressed that's the the neuro chemicals
going through your bloodstream can
actually be used to propel you you know
forward instead of cause you to retreat
what's a strategy that we can use to
interject the process so in my book
inner sighs there's there's a variety of
inner sizes which are mental and
emotional techniques to empower yourself
so number one is when we are in a state
of stress or fear or anxiety or panic
which is the the highest state you know
that that fear signal gets to the first
thing we we could understand is when
we're in that state of stress or anxiety
or fear or lack of conference or self
doubt our sympathetic nervous system has
just been triggered so we have the
sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous
system so first of all first to
understand is I have these two types of
nervous systems in my body one is for
flight flight or fight flight freeze or
faint and the other one is to be able to
be calm and respond so in the
sympathetic nervous system when we're in
a state of anxiety or stress or fear
we're not thinking properly we're
reacting based on our highest level of
training but what we can do very very
quickly is in a state of
dear doubter fear we can just stop stop
for just one second and do this simple
inner sizes call take six calm the
circuits so take six calm the circuits
is sixty breaths in through your nose
slowly slowly slowly slowly and then you
breathe out through your mouth like
you're breathing out through a straw as
slow as you can that's one when when we
do six of those we can show in fMRI
machines blood flow changing and moving
back to that left prefrontal cortex
which is our thinking brain when we do
those 60 breaths we actually move from a
sympathetic nervous system activation to
a parasympathetic system activation
which is a calm so I can respond so step
one is take six calm the circuits step
two is called iya which is AIA and step
two stands for awareness awareness of my
thoughts feelings emotions sensations
and my behaviors so stop what am I
thinking right now
what am i feeling right now what am i
sensing right now what what were my
behaviors well usually in the state of
stress you know we're contracted using
the state of stress you know we're
breathing a much more shallow usually in
a state of stress we have the foot on
the brake not the foot on the gas so
awareness and whenever we're practicing
awareness what we want to do is practice
it without judgment blame shame guilt or
justification let me repeat without
judgment blame shame guilt or
justification now why is that important
it's important because when you're
starting to observe your own processes
you don't want to be in a state of
labeling it anything it's just pure
awareness because it's the awareness
that now gives you the choice so if I'm
aware then I can change in an unaware
state I can so awareness of my thoughts
emotions feelings sensations behaviors
then you say okay
what's my intention right now is my
intention to walk across that room and
meet that guy or meet that girl or to
ask for the order you know or to ask for
a raise is that my intention yeah that's
my intention and then the third or the
second a is what's one little action
step that I could take right now and the
action step has got to be small because
you don't want to reactivate the stress
or fear Center so if you take one little
action step towards that your brain
feels safe you feel safe because you are
your brain right and so when we practice
take six calm the circuits first
practice ayah second AIA awareness
intention action now we've just
interrupted a pattern that may have been
a destructive or disempowering pattern
now I'm in control I'm focused I'm aware
and I create a positive pattern well
guess what happens do that for one day
do that for seven days thirty days six
months you all of a sudden are now in
control of your thoughts emotions
feelings behavior sensations and that is
how you achieve your goals if you're in
control you're directing if you're out
of control you're reacting and so which
which is going to give you a much more
empowered state and of course we know we
both know the answer so those are just
two inner sizes and there's many other
inner sizes you know that I teach in my
book and through my programs but that is
just the fundamental of a human being is
awareness and choice I love it
I've got a question here that I think
might really help some people that are
listening so let's say someone who's
listening in a route at the moment
really struggling to make a change in
their life how can someone get past that
story that they tell themselves what
would you tell them to do what's the
first steps how do they instantiate
their life in a new way what depends you
know how long they've been in a rut
right so there's a lot of work around
the power of story right and so you know
the story that goes on in our in on
mind about who we are why we are that
way what we believe what we expect what
we think we can achieve or have or do or
be that's a story so the first thing
that I share with you know my students
especially in our winning the game of
money programs that we have around brain
retraining is what would your new story
if you could write one out imagine
you're a Hollywood actor okay
and if you could write out a new script
that's not even true right now what
would you write out for your life so
forget the story you have if you had a
blank sheet of paper and you could write
out a story what would you write out and
I share with all my students a process
for doing this and it always starts off
like this I'm so happy and grateful for
the fact that I'm so happy and grateful
for the fact that now why do I start off
with that well what's two plus two
full is that a fact yes what's four plus
four eight is that a fact yes right so
our brain tends to believe facts so when
I start to write a story out I'm so
happy and grateful for the fact that I
am now earning X and now my physique is
this and my relationship is why am i and
my ink and my net worth is this on
traveling the world this I'm driving
this kind of car even though initially
when you write it out it's not true it's
not true and there's a part of you going
this [ __ ] well what happens you know
when you repeat something two times ten
times 20 times 100 times what happens
when you repeat it and emotionalize what
happens when your peated and
emotionalized and take small action
steps towards making that happen and to
prove my point I want to share something
with everybody that will show you how
this works let's say somebody tapped you
on the shoulder you know tomorrow or
today at a cafe or a restaurant or a bar
or wherever you go to work and the tap
dentist roll said oh my god I'm so and
so in Hollywood and we just finished
writing a script
and you look like a person that is this
script would you mind learning this
script that if you learn it will pay you
a million dollars to to perform it and
if you do it really well and you win an
Academy Award you'll get 10 million
dollars plus a whole bunch of stuff now
initially you might be afraid to go oh
my god I'm not an actor I'm not an
actress I don't know how to do this and
what if the person who tapped on it says
oh by the way we'll give you an acting
coach will give you you know
nutritionist will give you an exercise
girl will teach you everything and you
would practice the role that we have on
this sheet of paper on this pad of paper
if you practice the role every day every
week every month for the next year we're
gonna film in a year do you think you'd
learn the script do you think you'd be
able to memorize it do you think you'd
be able to raise your voice or lower it
based on the script do you think you
might hunch down a little bit this way
if you learned how to do that even
though today you don't know how to act
you don't know how to how to remember
lines you don't know how to you know
change if even if you don't know could
you get better at it
in 12 months and then have a camera in
front of you with other actors that have
practiced for 10 or 12 months every day
four five six seven eight hours day
could you remember that script and
possibly acted and the answer is of
course you could well why not write your
own script why not write you know the
kind of body you want the kind of energy
you want the amount of money you want
the way you want to travel the way you
want to be behaved and why do you write
the script and then become the script
over time because you be you you became
the script already that you believe
right now and fear was there and fear is
there now and limiting beliefs are there
and limiting beliefs now but when we
take our most powerful precious tool our
brain and we focus it on what we want
and how we can versus what we don't want
and why we can't then we're not in
control so the key is to get in control
use the tool better and prime your brain
every single day with the beliefs that
you want with the
self-image you want with the use of fear
so that it fuels you instead of it holds
you back I love it thinking about what
we think about determining our actions
and where we look determining where we
go
I was stood outside of a nightclub which
is why do I fill nightclubs that's my
job
stood outside on the front door and a
cyclist came around sec 11 o'clock at
night I don't know why anyone's on the
cycle at this time anyway comes blaring
around the corner and you can see
there's this car in front of him that he
really doesn't want to hit and he could
have easily missed it but his eyes were
just locked on this car the back of this
car sure enough where your eyes go is
where the bike goes through guys
straight into the back of it it was fine
when he was the embarrassment wasn't
fine but he was he walked away yeah
absolutely and so it all comes back down
to learning right how did listen at one
point right when we were babies you know
if if anybody who's watching this either
had a brother or sister or had their
baby their own at one point you know
baby will look up at his hand and
realize oh my god that's my hand and
they realized that you know moving I'm
moving my hand you know initially they
look at you maybe a ball or something in
front but then oh my god that's mine
well I like to do that with people's
brains I want people to understand that
you know you have this brain that maybe
you haven't learned how to optimize yet
you haven't learned some of the hacking
techniques to use the most powerful it's
the most powerful organism in the known
universe an organism in the known
universe and the problem is we have
operators that just are not trained
yeah there's no manual that comes with
life on foot that's right that's right
well well now we're getting some of that
manual right so now with the you know
the advancements in technology and fMRI
technology SPECT scan technology PET
scan technology where we can actually
start to see that the circuits the the
salience network the executive network
the default mode network in the brain
how they work what triggers them what
turns them on what turns them off we're
at a point in our
evolution of our species right where
it's like oh my god this is this is just
such such a powerful understanding
recognition that I can achieve a lot
more than I thought I could I could
become more I can have more I can give
more and and that's a really empowered
state to be in
what habit would you say it's had the
most positive impact on your life over
the last few years probably with I mean
there's a couple of them but probably
without any hesitation meditation which
I've been doing for thirty plus years
really is the one meditation and
mindfulness are very integrated but lets
you know meditation allows you to
recognize and know that there's
different states of consciousness that
you know I have a body I have organs I
have you know hands and feet and eyes
and ears but I'm not them that I'm
really one with it in this energetic
field that everybody else is in as well
that I could control my thoughts and my
emotions and I could activate them or
deactivate them at will and that life is
not happening to me right it's happening
for me when I could be aware of the
perfection of all of it and so
meditation would have to rank right up
there with oxygen for me yeah I get that
have you read Kemal Ravi can't love
yourself like your life depends on it
he's got he's got a wonderful bit in
that where he talks about life happens
to me like life happens for me life
happens through me I absolutely love
that there's a good friend he's a good
guy he was on not so long ago him and
James ol teacher and we're swimming in
were swimming in good waters um I want
to talk about the the difference between
the law of attraction and the law of
goya because for for a while the secret
the movie you
Blockbuster did really well the book is
well and for me there was something that
felt like it was missing and it's
absolutely been identified in the lore
of Goya would you be able to talk us
through that yeah when the movie the
secret came out you know the premise of
the book was think believe in you'll
achieve and that's [ __ ] it's it's
it's not it's that that's not how it
works it's you know the law of Goya I
learned if you if you spell out the word
attraction law of attraction the last
six letters of the word attraction is
action and nobody talked about that in
the movie the law of Goya is the get off
your ass law and you know Newton's
second law of motion says an object in
motion tends to stay in motion an object
at rest tends to stay at rest in the
physical world we live in this you know
quantum field but we also have this
physical experience and around health
wealth relationships career business
finances fun and experiences etc there
are behaviors right that if you know if
you take this behavior then X Y or Z
will happen and it's pretty predictable
the physical laws are so predictable we
can you know send a rocket ship to the
moon and time within a fraction of a
second and so in the physical world
there is a behavior that you need to
take if you want to lose weight or gain
weight we know that weight is calories
its energy right so you know one pound
is 3,500 calories you know one gram of
carbohydrates or one gram of fat you
know carbides is 4-4 calories fat is
nine calories that's energy if you want
to earn more money money is a means of
exchange between people countries etc so
if you want more money you have to
figure out how do I exchange what I have
product knowledge service companionship
you know for that exchange it's not
rocket science but it is a science and a
lot of people misunderstand this law of
attraction to some airy-fairy you know
think about it sit there
you know meditate and poof you know
you're gonna have these this wealth it's
just like where'd you get that idea the
law of attraction should be renamed to
the law of resonance so if you study you
know Tesla's work if you study Nikola
Tesla's work around energy all the way
to you know electricity and positrons
and electrons you understand that
resonance if you hit the a 440 key on
the piano how is it the ten feet away
the chandelier moves right that's
resonance so things that are in
resonance are attracted to each other
not like a magnet because if you take
you know positive and negative and
positive and a magnet and repels but if
you understand that if you are in
resonance with the people the vision the
goals that you have and you get your
head your heart and your gut in
alignment in resonance then you are
basically doing with your brain the same
thing that a radio dial does on a radio
station if you're at 90 let's say five
point five that's maybe rock-and-roll
you're in resonance with that
vibrational frequency if you're ninety
five point six that might be punk rock
95.7 might be classical music so the key
for us humans is how do we get into
resonance with the frequencies of what
it is that we want to achieve health
wealth relationships career business
everything is energy in the universe and
that means that everything is amplified
at a certain vibrational sequence and if
you get into alignment into resonance
that's the law of attraction it's not
some magical Airy fairy pixie dust you
know think believing you'll achieve get
your head your heart your gut and your
behaviors aligned and then you will be
in residence and all of a sudden
everything that you want is right there
already the action was the missing step
to me that was what that was where I
thought I didn't I didn't quite get it
but you totally correct and
as well by leading with that action it
feeds back in all of these feed into
each other right the way that you feel
the way that you your gut and your
passions are with regards to what you're
doing in life and then your actions feed
back into that so there's that there's
one other piece to it though and this is
this is the peach that a lot of people
just forget there's nobody who's
watching or listening to this right now
okay that I believe there might be but
very very rare that somebody's trying to
figure how to colonize Mars right now so
for everything else for getting in great
shape for making more money for starting
a business for writing a book for
starting a podcast for whatever you want
all the how-to already exists all the
how-to all the blueprint of do this do
this do this so what I was going to say
is when we're thinking about taking
action you have to take the right
actions in the right order at the right
time so one of the things that everybody
is responsible for is to say okay before
I act what should I be doing when should
I be doing it how should I be doing it
and that is one of the other biggest
mistakes most people make the think that
oh I'm in action well you could be in
action doing the wrong damn things so
stop doing the wrong damn things and
find that what should I be doing and
here's the beautiful thing there are
experts in everything that you and I
want and all of the books programs see
these courses coaching consulting is
available or YouTube video or Google so
it's already available so all you need
to do is say okay what's my goal what
are you know what what do I need to
think what I need to feel and then what
do I need to do do that and guess what
you'll be in resonance and you'll
achieve your goals and dreams faster and
easier than ever before there's
certainly a lot of people I know that
I'm one of them I have to work very hard
at planning so naturally I would just
just do something I would just blur out
I'll just I'll just start start doing
and taking that moment to consider and
to lay out the plan I feel it can make a
huge difference perfect example if
that's when I go on a holiday but when
you go on a holiday and if you've ever
done it a not planned where you're gonna
be on particular days
and you can write it off as an excuse me
well you know I just want to I just want
to kind of feel my way around the town I
don't want to be stuck to a rigid
schedule I promise you if you plan a
holiday and you've got tore on day one
and a beach trip on day two and this any
other ego you get so much more out of
your time unbelievable the holiday
holiday hacks 101 there for you so yeah
I want to finish up and and ask about
what you think but where you would
direct people if they want to find out a
little bit more or if there is some
books in a size I can't recommend it
more highly like will be linked in the
show notes below of course if this is
why else have you been struck by that
you've consumed recently or over the
last few years that you thoughts really
a value Wow listen I I know you've had
my friend James clear on before and so
habits are really you know mastering
habits so whoever is watching this you
know listened to that podcast as well he
does a great job of dissecting pod cat
or the habit loop and the stuff in there
I think the the stuff that I'm really
fascinated with right now is
consciousness and just understanding you
know the nature of consciousness the
nature of you know why and how we make
decisions and and and really leveling up
our awareness to the magic of being
human you know and the gift that this is
it's just so it's like mind-boggling
complex and spectacular and and so yeah
for anybody who likes it likes this kind
of stuff and how do I become more and
have more and give more follow my work
I'm all over social media on Instagram
and on Facebook Fanpage I do trainings
every week for free and I have a a
little Facebook fan page called achieve
even more that's a private community
that I give free stuff away in as well
so read my books and follow some of my
work John that's awesome and thank you
so much I have to say I really
absolutely love what you're doing I
think that you're doing Lee making a
great change there's been a total
pleasure to get you on here like he said
all will be linked in the show notes
below if you want to follow John online
you know what go show notes we'll have
that in as well like share and subscribe
but for now
thank you John thank you so much
[Music]